Hello, and welcome to another
episode of GDL-IL--
GDL Israel.
Today we're going to go over
real briefly on several
updates and news that I gather,
and I'll try to share
with you some of the useful
links that I'm
using day in, day out.
We had this week here in Campus
Tel Aviv, a great event
on Google Cloud and all the new
features, services, and
new APIs that you
could leverage.
And I'll put in the show notes
the links to one other
recording from this event, and
second, the presentation, so
even if you missed it, you
will be able to check the
videos, and of course,
go with the slides.
So without further ado, let me
just share my screen with you
and let's jump right in.
This is a place where I'm trying
to gather old and new
cool things that are happening
in Chrome platform, in Chrome
environment.
Now for those of you that are
not aware, today Chrome is
quite a huge platform.
It's not only the browser, which
is very, very popular
and conquering more and more
users every day, it's Chrome,
Chrome on Mobile, of course
Chrome on Android, Chrome on
iOS, Chrome in Google TV, and
of course, Chrome in all
[INAUDIBLE]
laptop, desktop, mobile
devices, and tablets.
So from four inch screen size up
to 70 or 90 inch TV, you've
got Chrome there
as a platform.
Not to mention Chrome OS with
all the great new devices,
like the Pixel and the
Chromebook and the ChromeVox
that letting you enjoy this
powerful ecosystem.
So this is the site.
I'll try just to put it maybe a
bit bigger here, so for the
ones of you that watch
it afterwards--
let's just do that.
So this is the link.
And one of the very new, cool
things that I put here is some
summary of all Chrome
use that are
happening around the world.
And we just touch about
a few of them.
So first and foremost is this
great source that if you are
not aware of-- it's Peter
Beverloo blog, and he's one of
the powerful, great guys out
there that is bringing to us
all the latest and greatest in
terms of what's going on in
Chromium Open Source Project.
So if you want to save yourself
the trouble of going
and do a commitdiff and trying
to check and see what are all
the thousands of contributors
or hundreds of contributors
are doing inside Blink,
Chromium, et cetera.
Peter is bringing us almost on
a weekly basis all the latest
and greatest in terms of news,
and as you can see here, there
are some very, very
nice things.
Some are really important, like
we going to have now a
new, fancy dinosaur on all the
offline page in Chrome.
Let me make it bigger so
it will be better.
Yes.
So this is a very important
one, of course.
But there are some real
important features that you
might want to check and see how
they are influencing your
mobile web app or your desktop
next development or project.
So this is one source--
Peter.sh.
Let me put it a bit bigger here
so you could all see it
later on nicely as well.
So this is the site.
Definitely register to his RSS
feed or just check out the
blog from time to time, because
you get a great, great
summary of what's going on
inside the Chrome kingdom.
Another great source, that
basically it's just a few
other links over here, is
Chrome Release blog.
So I got this week few questions
from developers--
how can I be updated about
new channels that are
being pushed live?
And as you all know, Chrome is
being updated every six weeks.
And in this Google Chrome
Releases blog--
this is the URL, of course--
you could just keep yourself
updated on all the new things
that are happening and
are going out there.
It could be the dev channel
[INAUDIBLE], it could be the
beta, it could be their release
candidate, and of
course, the final versions
of Chrome.
And one of the nice things here
is that you could also
register yourself to
certain labels.
So if you, let's say, interested
in Chrome for iOS
or Chrome Better Version,
because you want to test
things automatically before they
are being pushed to their
final version, you could just
go, and as you see here, very
easily go on a specific label
and just keep yourself update
with this specific
type of Chrome.
Other useful links are here.
The official Chromium blog and
Chrome blog, of course, and
for those of you that are active
on G+, you probably
want to follow Chrome on G+.
Another great source that
I found from time
to time quite helpful--
it's an unofficial source, but
nevertheless, it's bringing
some new, exciting things
into your place--
is just this blog which called
Google System Blog post.
Again, it's unofficial blog, but
from time to time, I find
myself checking out what's going
on here, and they're
pretty good at catching and
updating what's going on in
Google ecosystem.
In terms of what happening in
the past month-- so I had this
really cool event about startups
and the slides are
here, so you are most welcome
to check them out.
Except that we did several very
interesting GDLs in July.
If you want to test the water
and see what is Compute Engine
and what is all about, please go
ahead and check this link.
Let's open it and see.
So this is basically a short
tutorial that I put and it's
part, of course, of GDL-IL
series, which lets you test
the water if you will.
On Compute Engine,
quite quickly--
it's written here
five minutes.
I guess that for some of you,
it will take even less.
If you're taking out all the
manual process of putting the
billing in place, then very
quickly you could launch your
own virtual Box.
It might be CentOS, might be
Debian, and quite quickly you
could work and be productive
on it.
Some very, very interesting
things--
here are all the five easy steps
that you need to follow.
And another very important
link that I would love to
share with you is the
cloud.google.com.
Basically on this one URL, we're
trying to gather all the
vast, enormous actually,
offering in our Cloud
resources, products,
and solutions.
So quite quickly, if you're
going to this one link, you
could click on Products and
see all the different area
that you could utilize
and leverage.
And in our specific
case-- let's jump
in to Compute Engine--
quite quickly you could see what
are the benefits, what
are the main features
that you gaining.
If you wish you compare it with
a current Cloud provider
or a current, let's say, private
Cloud that you are
using or any other different
solution, quite quickly here
you could find what will move
the needle for you and then
follow up on it and make sure
that this is the right tool
for the job.
One click here and you could
try it, and it's again
something very, very cool to
check out, specifically, if
you have cases where Google App
Engine is not support your
specific technology.
Without mentioning names, I met
big company that's still
using Perl in production, and
of course, Google App Engine
would be a good solution
for them.
But they definitely wanted to
test and check Compute Engine
because their working with
Debian in production, and then
it might be a perfect
solution for them.
BigQuery--
it's another very interesting
big topic.
If you have terabytes of log or
any other big data that you
want to check, here in this
episode of GDL-IL, I just show
you how you could work with
BigQuery from JavaScript, and
most specifically from
Appscript, and be productive
with it and analyze your
enormous data.
It's quite amazing to see
BigQuery these days, because
in that specific example, we
showed how you are slicing and
dicing more than 400 gigabytes
of data from HttpArchive and
basically getting for some real
interesting insights in
terms of trends on what
going on the leading
sites on the web.
So this is the place where you
want to check it, BigQuery
Power With JavaScript, and quite
quickly here you could
see how easy it is to work with
simple SQL statements
like these that are returning in
less than a few seconds and
letting you have some
interesting thought and
results out of it.
In this specific example by the
way, we are going all over
Wikipedia and just seeing what
are the most popular topics,
articles basically, that's
being changed.
And here you can see the
leading of the table.
And this is the example that I
mentioned about HttpArchive
and how you could utilize
this specific
big data with BigQuery.
Last but not least is, of
course, what I mentioned--
yesterday, we had a big Cloud
event, and this is
the summary of it.
And you have here the slides and
of course more than three
hours of talks that you are most
welcome to just watch and
see what's interesting
for you.
So let's see, today as
I promised, we're
going to keep it short.
We have a few people
here that I see.
If someone have any questions,
now is a perfect time to ask,
and if not, just please feel
free to reach out on me on
GBlast, Twitter, or
any other channel.
Let me put here, again, just so
you could see what is the
best channels.
So on G+, of course, it will be
GreenIdo in one word, and
on Twitter, it will
be the same.
Just use whatever channel you
feel comfortable with.
And of course, we have here down
at the bottom a summary
of all the GDL Israel episodes
that we had in the past.
Quite a lot of really good
content here, so if you
interesting in design, in web
components, HTML5, Chrome,
Chrome OS, Angular, and more and
more, just feel free to go
here and check it out.
So until next time, thank you
very much for joining me.
And I hope that you'll have
a very productive week.
Bye bye.